anyway okay maybe you will return to
normal chests or maybe we'll play John
John's
if John John's is challenging me John oh
yeah let's play John John without Zen
mode okay good luck John John's oh I
played John John's once before it's been
a while and it's hard to transition from
Horde and back to normal chess I'll play
let's play something normal and Bishop
Bishop e5 John John's playing a Berlin
okay let's play a four Knights
I don't want to play Overland I played
this position from the black side Indy
696 invites d4
in Bach usually when black plays this
early d6 ideas we put both bishops in
the center and then castle Bishop d7
yeah let's castle I'm trying to remember
there's a game there's a very famous
game between tirage and Mariko and I
can't remember and it's driving me crazy
right now they're booking one like I
spent so much time like analyzing this
kind of famous classic game I think it's
Ricky one it might not be but
yeah brookey one
after the scheme all show which game I'm
referring to well it's one of the
classic games of like of all time and I
think we're actually kind of following
it there's also a Sam Shanklin game in a
similar position
[Music]
so essentially even starting here
there's there's a very long calculation
yeah and I know the first several moves
so Queen takes so essentially I went a
pawn but I lose a pawn back because he
for though the work is overworked here
so I can take on e4 with a bishop yeah
and then again I'm just playing out
playing all my moves from memory
I believe it's takes takes 93 with a
skewer if if f5 I have a three
yeah five f3 Bishop c5 Knight takes e5
Knight takes e5 Bishop g5 rook t5 and
then c4 rook moves somewhere Bishop e7
and I skewer the the fork the the c5
Knight and there were kind of fades so I
think that's how it goes
this is like a classic game because it's
all it's all calculation like starting
with Bishop takes c6 it was just pure
initiative a5 has only move here if rook
d4 F 3 is just winning and 93 is a very
important move to basically unleash the
e-file and block the road
I guess I don't know if john-john's is
listening but you guys has to decide
between these moves yes f5 f3 I've shown
this to students and like after Bishop
c5 a lot of them struggle to find the
continuation take some visualg 5 because
King f1 looks very natural the problem
with King f1 is the bishop can move back
and then after takes takes me before
there's g5 so have to take here and then
Bishop Bishop g5 it's incredible how
initiative continues through the end of
the game like we're already in that game
so basically from from the opening to
that game
there's just non-stop threats or
captures and the line I mentioned before
rook t5c for sure I don't know if after
rook t5 officially savviness better or
c4 it shouldn't make a difference
of a vague memory that tirage played see
for I know he played Bishop e7 I think
well afterwards all I'll show the game
yeah so rook e8 it's a try but Bishop e7
now we'll simplify rook let's play rook
here and then bring mother again
yeah I definitely don't want to mess up
the ending after after remembering like
the whole the whole opening let's take a
pond got you a spawn if Night Moves I
win this pond do I have some meeting
like g4 I'm low on time let's not mess
around let's just take it on
I'll stop blunder anything either waking
up to defend let's push
play be three just safety first played
before I want to play this the knight of
seven Oh John John is definitely trying
to to play against my time running the
pawn spending the night yeah box pretty
much tied down hmm
Oh where's my meat probably this move
okay got the job done
thanks for the game John John's yeah
hopefully this will be instructive for a
lot of people going back to yeah to this
position now I don't think the the
tirage game will be in the database but
there have been a few games do a quick
Google search
oh thanks for the game John John's
and for the bits yeah there's definitely
definitely want to find an improvement
let me see if I can view you PGN yeah
and then copy and then paste so yeah we
followed we got to the same position and
yeah this has all been played before
at Ross played bishop in southern person
then c4 and Mariko just resigned and
Shanklin Tali game Shanklin down a game
where he played d3 let some game like
this t3 here here and something like
this where he played d4 a six or maybe
d4 castling or came one a six yeah this
game which England played listen in 2016
are the same calculation like 93 f5 f3
it was very nice flow so that's why you
should know your classics hopefully
people can learn something from that
but yeah next time if you're climbing
black I think most people these days
play Bishop c5 even though again it's
four Knights like Knight c3 you can play
Bishop c5 or vision before anyway
yeah we'll move on maybe that'll go on
YouTube